it's time for weekend scramble this week
we've got whopping blunder Kobe denied
and the expensive damage
there's no that's just expensive damage
well I got some better news though okay
we got a board game that just came out
on Kickstarter go check it out the link
is gonna be in the description box below
it's called shady agent when do we get
to plan we play very soon I can't wait
I'm actually gonna invite every single
person I know to play that [ __ ] I'm
excited it's pretty dope I will say
those drawings are highly accurate it is
they are except for except for why are
you a gypsy nobody it's pretty accurate
she always has a gut feeling yeah yeah
witches have cats I don't know they say
cats are like a witch gypsy gypsies have
crystal balls and stuff and you know
what's crazy so a fortune-teller it's
not appropriate it's a line of cats I
think I think they have cat so we just
released this yesterday right
hmm and we're almost we almost met our
goal of 25,000 like and it was only one
day mm-hmm it's freaking nuts like I
didn't think that I was kind of scared
because I was like I don't think I don't
think the fans are gonna buy it I would
buy it yeah but you guys should check it
out because it's our first time doing a
Kickstarter that's so cool yeah yeah
we've never done one yeah we never done
one because so when we did it we wanted
to do something like super special
that's really cool yeah yeah I like
everyone's characters thank you you're
gonna enjoy the game Nikki because we
get to talk about shady stories of each
other oh you'll get to roast a [ __ ] out
each other and question if people are
lying or not Kellyanne so it's gonna be
very fun town give me the game can we
play that now are you gonna finally play
with those davidann JK party cuz you
always like flake on us I don't flake I
just don't go exactly we don't do
punishments any mileage it's a I don't
want to go
punishment no I just don't have time
well you're a character you have to but
every time I go to your office you're
just watching TV I don't get it you're
gonna go in your office yeah I go the
office once every no then yeah but
you're watching TV for hours first of
all the last time I was there the DMV
for four hours I had a migraine how do
you have that kind of time yeah make an
appointment
what is sir I do have an appointment
what yeah and you were still over for
yeah miss sucked I don't go to the DMV
[ __ ] that drive without a license all
right for our first story Burger King in
Russia had to apologize because they had
this promotion where they were offering
women who got pregnant by soccer players
for the World Cup yeah it would offer
him what was it like a like a prize
that's a good deal that is a good
problem so this is the translation it
says Burger King within the framework of
social responsibility has appointed a
reward for girls who get pregnant from
the stars of world football each will
receive three million rubles and a
lifelong supply of whoppers for these
girls it will be possible to get the
best football genes and will lay down
the success of the Russian national team
on several generations ahead forward we
believe in you is it the girls that
didn't get impregnated an outrage do it
well how am I gonna get a discount if I
couldn't snag a football player this is
joke was it for real this is what they
posted on the Burger King Russia
Facebook that's how I love Russia that's
freakin hilarious for guys I don't think
any girl was like is any girl taking it
as a joke
I mean I don't think it was just girls I
got offended is just everyone got
offended I don't find that offensive at
all I think it's just ridiculous why cuz
guys are like how am I gonna get this
discount if they can't impregnate me
we're also a reckless way to bring a
child into the world I want to take them
seriously at all
I thought that if a girl who really was
pregnant by a sports star would go in
and they're like no we were joking dude
you're crazy
ah like that's what I thought they're
real they're serious they need to make
their jokes more clear I mean I guess
their sense of humor is very different
because previously we had they had this
other thing that they posted so last
year
in Russia they released an ad depicting
a 17 year old victim of rape and beating
where she was they pretty much made a
meme out of her describing like how much
she drank that night yeah
and so Burger King used her image that
Burger King is [ __ ] it and like they
were pretty much saying like this is how
much time you have left before this
promotion is over gangster over there so
what like hardcore dude I'd love to be
part of that marketing team room well
then okay you know that girl that just
got right what if we took that part in
the news story where she goes like this
well that was made into a meme already
okay I mean oh but strangely though that
makes me want to eat their burgers cuz
I'm like if they're a company is this
crazy how crazy is your food then you go
and it's like it's the same [ __ ] gotcha
you just said human food oh that's kind
of cool yeah I was like oh [ __ ] a quote
spans the real question is well when in
Russia who's the weird it's so weird
that I don't even argue it no don't win
in Russia you got a do Russian [ __ ] but
even Russians don't want to do Russian
[ __ ] yeah they do
no they don't there's all of the
Americans getting outraged she just said
Russian yeah she did say Russia said
everyone is outraged the Russian dudes
that can't get impregnated and get the
discount she said everyone that's
Russian every single cat dog mouse so
like Yugoslavians - is that part of
Russia used to well then probably what
about Ukrainians what about China what
the [ __ ] does that have anything to do
with it I could totally picture like
other fast food chains in Russia having
to compete and insta like a McDonald's
commercial would be like a kid that says
he just lost his whole family in a fire
and
happy meal here that'd be the crazy
that's how they're marking yeah like
computer you need to be on their mark I
should that's what I'm like this is
hilarious total bail should do the kid a
little Mexican kids in Walmart then too
huh
that's all bad a little too far huh yeah
no that's like Wendy's Wendy's would be
like that the yellow kid at Walmart like
that oh yeah yeah and then like he gets
fined and it's like oh you got to pay
money and go to jail because you did a
what do you call it obstruction of
[ __ ] peace and then when he's in jail
have a Wendy's the cop hands I'm a
Wendy's Burger even Oh like he has
brutality and like they're kicking his
ass they drag him out you know the only
thing yeah yeah yeah use a Wendy's you
know like they still feed you Burger
King doesn't stand by Russia's team
because this is what they said we are
sorry about the clearly offensive
promotion that the team in Russia
launched online as soon as it was
brought to our attention we had to
remove de certainly does not reflect our
brand or our values and we are taking
steps to ensure this type of activity
does not let's make these commercials
let's I like I just I just like tragedy
commercials but hey look at the brighter
side you get a taco a whopper there you
get a whopper like right now you know
the there's a separation of families oh
no so sad
he went there Wow and then David stopped
himself yeah yeah because I'm a lot
smarter than these people but you get a
del Taco oh speaking of tacos that's
horrible Taco Bell has a taco shell made
of chicken yeah she's delicious haven't
you tried it man naked taco or something
right I swear Taco Bell they just get
stoned and they're like what do we want
do we make the kitchen because Tim was
like have you heard of this [ __ ] and
then we're go on the way to San Diego
and I was like let's just get it it
sounds disgusting
but it's good it's actually pretty good
do you guys get just do Black Mountain
Baha Baha blast the [ __ ] I love the
color
I like do blast better sometimes the
color of drinks make me drink them I
can't drink that I call it drinks I
can't drink him why cuz that [ __ ] looks
like Windex this one throws like Windex
right this one throws me off because
it's protein oh right
or the gelatin or what is this product
it's like a protein drink yeah but like
where's the protein come from gelatin
that's what I don't know but it's this
is a protein mukau blue raspberry
no I wish I really wish it's [ __ ]
expensive
I really wish oh how much I hope your
sponsor me please I get that with the
colors okay when it's frosty like when
it's like that that frosty cold like a
Slurpee yeah yeah yeah but like remember
when weighing Gatorade had that like
Mountain rush and they had those like
those like murky milky colors oh alright
next story
Kobe Bryant was denied membership into
the Academy of Motion Pictures Arts and
Science why cuz they're like they're
like [ __ ] you can't act is that why did
he get a nomination yeah he got he won
an Oscar party don't win it right but
winning an Oscar doesn't guarantee you a
membership wait he got an Oscar for what
for that movie that he weird ear
basketball he has a short film what an
animated short what do you need to get
in red the Oscar party yeah you came huh
we know he doesn't listen to [ __ ] that's
true he was playing a fly yes well I
guessed that like half of that [ __ ]
right Oscar Mayer we do you want an
Oscar for that animated I wasn't there
when that happened I'm pretty sure you I
was there when shape of waters shape of
water was ready you guys were there
before we were and we saw that yeah he's
like no you were there brother Tycho
Tycho was [ __ ] barfing on the Dean's
beard and that was more entertaining
than that [ __ ] hmm then you should have
said that you little liar I'll remember
I just remember a shape of water because
they buck the [ __ ] reptile uh-huh
yes anyway the the Oscar winners and
nominees they are automatically
considered for membership but they're
not guaranteed and so apparently the
reason why they denied him was because
he body of work in the film industry
yeah that's right that's pretty cool
well that was in like if you pick if you
say if you think Sports is filled that
[ __ ] he's in a lot of films he's been on
TV quite well that's crazy he has a lack
of a body of work and he already won an
Oscar for one thing yeah like all these
people alike will look at my portfolio
and he's like I'm gonna make this and
win an Oscar al Ghul [ __ ] about no
Oscars in this article here they are
also bringing up his past all come on
with the whole sexual assault case and
the fact that so he has that and then do
you know how many rapists there are in
Hollywood me is like trying to do The
Times up and the hash tag me to movement
but literally [ __ ] have that so with
the poly wouldn't either go to jail or
not I mean they're not saying the times
of them saying that that's the reason
why she was denied he's just like
they're bringing up another Oh possible
reason oh I see also time is bringing
that up yeah times is bringing times you
should shut that [ __ ] down then you
[ __ ] [ __ ] you just trying to stir
controversy for no [ __ ] reason you
[ __ ] you're just yeah the news [ __ ]
being a part of Hollywood or raping and
all that [ __ ] is like a prerequisite man
everyone's involved in that [ __ ]
I hope it's not anymore because they're
saying here that there was a petition
where thousands of people signed
demanding that the nomination for deer
basketball do you rescinded because it
because of the and that's literally
everybody up there who got an Oscar yep
take them all down take every single
person take take them all down as we've
been hearing about like Kevin Spacey
stories like since five ten years ago
before anything surf is like everyone
that we knew that was already in
Hollywood knew who all the crazy what
did you pull the whistle why didn't you
I knew
sounds like rumors that I knew on
Twitter and it's false
no and I honestly I thought it was the
norm so I was like okay so if we want to
get our movie soul I just gotta let a
guy like grab my booty that's horrible
what do you mean you're I'm entering
their game how do you know When in Rome
you do Roman [ __ ] have you seen his
booty it's pretty big no that's what I
know like for example when you join a
fraternity you know they're gonna make
you [ __ ] like bite on glass or some
[ __ ] so I don't [ __ ] with the
institution like if I'm gonna join the
institution I'm gonna do whatever they
want me to do but then the whole point
of speaking out is so you can change the
way you can't speak out on rumors though
you gotta be harassed first and he
didn't even get the [ __ ] fortunate
chance of being harassed so what with
what I said I knew about Weinstein in
[ __ ] two thousand seven or eight in
rumor before Twitter even [ __ ] opened
up inhuman rumor oh because okay so my
friend is a filmmaker in Vietnam right
so he was out in Asia and Weinstein was
in like Hong Kong or whatever but he's
he's known to license a lot of Asian
films in the US and all that [ __ ] right
so his company does that because he
loves asian women but obviously now he
just loves all women because he just
wants to rape them all but he
propositioned one of his actors like
they were having a meeting but then his
assistant asked specifically for her to
go up there when she came back she was
[ __ ] feeling like [ __ ] she was like I
[ __ ] told him no and then she
basically said that he propositioned me
for sex for the role and all that stuff
yeah and then she's like I have what I
didn't take it and yes she doesn't care
about a career stop it I think she's a
Chinese or Vietnam act actress but she's
married and all that and she wants to do
legit work right so she's like yeah
there's a lot of girls in the industry
that will do it but I did it and then
that's you know our buddy of ours that's
the story that he told us and this is
out in 2008 and I was like damn so
that's what you got to get it do to to
get a film made that's sad that's the
the point of that thing
you know not to you know to his credit
his mentality is what people thought the
norm was you know what I mean so it's
like in order for me to do this I have
to do this yeah so like there was like
issues of people who are doing that me
to boo me for example like Kim
Kardashian she was hashtag me to is I
know you're a little different yeah you
benefited and that was she's a part of
the problem
so like the meet to movement it was
supposed to be people who were coerced
they had no other options versus
somebody who did what they had to do and
they got what they wanted and now
they're good and now you're trying to
come on dude yeah cuz then women like
that that I got what they wanted I like
they just perpetuated by exactly so they
were part of the problem you know versus
like you know all the other stories that
came out where they were it was like
some shitty situations you know and I
would have been part of the problem then
oh for sure you would you wait then
you're saying that no porn stars can say
me to when I feel like they've got the
biggest the most amount of stories where
it's like this is what they do for work
and this is what they do in private but
a lot of people think that they can just
go ask them touch on them yeah molest
them on in private and that's not right
right that's like that's weird
Oh ever a lot of people o people are
weird about porn stars they think that
they think their [ __ ] machine yeah
they're just they're objects they don't
see them as actresses right yeah or
people that's like if I saw a [ __ ]
jenna jameson walking down the street I
just start beating off like what's up
girl yeah yeah but people yeah that's
all and so even though comedy people go
up to you and say hey do that accent or
whatever oh yeah that's true they don't
even see us as human beings yeah do that
[ __ ] thing do that [ __ ] thing and
I'm like I'm like I'm happy to be a
clown up I'm like I'm [ __ ] feeding my
son right now they're just like oh do it
now do right know what I love you dance
monkey dance I don't like I don't like
doing that [ __ ] if I just got in a fight
or something and I'm upset right it's
like [ __ ] do you even know what
I just lived through [ __ ] you
don't care dance monkey but if I'm in a
good mood hey how you doing everybody
the problem I'd rather suck at dating
and be a monkey though I'll give a [ __ ]
give me the little symbols
all right for the last story those this
five-year-old Kansas boy who climbed on
top of a sculpture and his parents were
hit with a one hundred and thirty two
thousand dollar bill and I'm gonna show
you guys don't want you treating my
little skull polished it well let's see
cuz some kids are [ __ ] horrible so
respect just so you know these people
aren't the parents not a museum yeah or
like a community center game where they
had things on display torture and the
kid there's two kids but watch the one
that goes here where's the parents at
leave it for swinging on ours two kids
oh oh wait here it is yes oh my gosh
he's like pulling it down hmm
oh wow oh my where are the parents
I'll tell you in a second why those
adults not doing anything well she is
she was like hey yo okay good girl and
then they broke the statue that kid run
for it oh man so the parents said that
they were out of view from the security
camera but apparently that they were
nearby saying goodbye to friends for
after like a wedding party yeah do men
in that split-second is when I got away
from those kids are scared enough oh I
get it
every parent thinks that their kid is
like oh so [ __ ] angelic right you
know what the the [ __ ] excuse was oh
my son is such a sweetheart he was just
trying to hug the statue so much why
don't they just say hey you know what we
[ __ ] up they just moved you know kids
man know kids are smart bacteria
probably told the mom that cuz kids are
[ __ ] smart and yeah
are they of the kakizou nature a hundred
percent yeah because they ancient Asian
people talk [ __ ] about their kids like
immediately you don't mean and they
blame you for [ __ ] even do yet don't
don't don't [ __ ] blame the other kid
for just being there that kid will get
beat dude my mom would be like as soon
as she's like I'm gonna talk [ __ ] about
my kid first so that they know what the
[ __ ] they're getting into some they'd be
like Oh your daughter's like no she's a
piece of [ __ ] she talks back she does
this and I'm like doing okay if that's
that you tell my mom would like to know
who did it he did you got my god I'm in
the other room yeah I remember when I
was a kid we we ate at a restaurant got
really sick from the food and had throw
up and then my mom was talking [ __ ]
about me that [ __ ] like this guy is such
a savage she was embarrassed for herself
the fact that I threw up eating on a
restaurant like this Korean restaurant
my mom was a kid and then I was swinging
in the chair like this right you little
[ __ ] admit ice I swung all the way back
I fell on the ground in my head hit the
tile I started crying and my mom got on
me I saw a bee in my ass why not [ __ ]
did you do that I told you not to swing
the champ
I get it I would have kicked your house
too I was expecting oh that's different
and my kid fell his back and said I
would lift him back up and I slapped him
upside the head yeah wrong crowd buddy
hey that's how I wish to add white
parents because they would have sued the
restaurant for having faulty chairs what
I feel like it's like why West LA super
you know it's not it's not the south
it's not I don't think Nikki's mom would
do that no no because Nikki's mom likes
Hawaiian boys fake white boys parents
are saying that it's not fair that they
got hit with the bill because it was the
the places fault because they did not
being super cool in permanently its hat
like it was not permanently attaching
that it wasn't secure enough oh yeah you
know it was
fools with cliff it's a great great
argument and so yeah they're saying that
like you know that we shouldn't pay for
it because it wasn't even our far we're
not negligent parents we were just
saying goodbye to friends I saw those
two kids running around I'm saying those
kids aren't scared enough yeah like
before you go say bye you were supposed
to look at your kids stay right here
before I [ __ ] murder you you [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] yeah and then you hug your
friends and they're still there and you
go don't touch anything not let go of
his hand if I know I'm gonna play ball
for sure
no like you're staying with you you're
not breaking [ __ ] yeah I was pretty
reckless I probably broke a lot of
things but I don't remember it you're
still reckless that sucks too like I
don't you know like teach your kids how
to be responsible
I don't worry things I touch exactly
you're teaching your kids that it's
everything else is fault if you [ __ ] up
it's something else is that cuz like for
sure I think oh that's why I wish I had
less you I think I'll have my kid grab a
statue and I push the statue on his face
I was looking at those kids on my [ __ ]
shitty kids and then I remember that
when I was five I said a building on
fire so I was like a partition to say
anything yeah but I want to set a
building on fire and my parents protect
me and say the building wasn't secure
enough flammable why'd you put a fire
why'd you build it out of wood where's
the sprinklers that's what I want I want
that kind of parent I want the kind of
parent that helps me during PTA time I
you know I always wanted my mom read
during the PTA
[Music]
[Music]